honey no man bootleg Capcom we live from
the x5 Southwest funk ownership boo like
calves showcase my doom aunt is he just
headline that dang it tore to pieces
funk volume homie how you feel about yo
thank you for allowing me to do that man
come on man that's a life point though
man you're headlining show at South by
Southwest come on that what you deserve
it man you deserve it last year you made
the double XL cover besides Jaron who I
know you guys are campaigning hard for
to get on that that new one who else
give me two or three guys you think
should be on it um isaiah rashad chance
the rapper for sure I know you're gonna
be on there I would like to see Casey
Veggies on there like a wild card like
someone who you know might be low
surprising who I would like a little
surprising snow tha product like if she
just if she was able to get on it I
think that would just be like I don't
that would be [__] owe ya a shout out
to snow shout out the Snowman all right
so uh last piece of music we got from
you was the Golden Age mixtape which was
[__] bananas um I know funk volume
got some big things in the works this
year what do you got coming up man yeah
man I gotta you know everything that I
do is for an album that I'm a drop at
the end of the year and I mean but I got
a EP bout to come out cause state of
mind it's just where i met you know just
the more quality dizzy wright but it's
you know just that i'm thinking the
knowledge that i want the world to have
and you know soak up and that's just
what it is is there any um like collabs
that that uh that you're trying to work
on that might might not be you know some
some maybe some ideal collabs that maybe
are in the works but you know that you'd
like to see happen on the album i love
you i got we got to get a bone feature
oh yeah we definitely got to get that
official bone feature yeah for sure
official official official i know you
did the door lazy and futurist
and that [__] is fly that like shout out
to Futuristics actually the super fly
but we gotta get that official like and
they want to make it happen so that's
why like my album is gonna be everything
yeah I mean that [__] won't you know
but who I really want to work with his
big krit like we just chopped it I saw
that on was a Twitter we finally kind of
like chopped it up and uh hopefully we
could make that happen like he's a good
dude and he's a dope ass Robert oh man
and producer yeah yeah yeahs cream I d
better producing the right man he just
end up saying I'll go to producing he
just knows how to you know do that [__]
better than most [__] because he
creates it so I'm like I really want to
work the crib um production wise man you
guys got Cato in-house I know you've
been working with it with a lot of the
same cast for a minute but are you uh
stepping outside of your box that I try
to get you linked up a hit boy I don't
know if you ended up meeting he was over
here but yeah I'd get to meet him yet no
I'm definitely trying to step outside my
box any produce you're trying to work
with or any or anything that's in the
works already um not particular man like
you know you know you got your flight
like mike will made-it yeah man he got
he got that fly [__] like but it's just
all about them producers that create
that you know a better sound for dizzy
Wright if you send me a bunch of [__]
that already sound exactly like what I
got I'm not gonna [__] with that [__]
cuz you know it's about progressing yeah
i mean so i like to [__] with people who
think like that yeah I me you give me a
three or four of your if you had to and
those are hard questions I'm not asking
to give me the top but gimme gimme like
off the top of your head top three four
albums of all time whoa two of those
albums is a collection favorite okay two
of those albums is like my favorite
album is bone thugs-n-harmony are the
world one and two okay together so those
two album body rot yeah like all that
[__] hate nation a lot of that [__] is
just like that's what I that's what I go
to when I need to get in my zone so but
then like
damian marley and nas read on that
reggae mix with the hip hop is like that
was perfect for me in my Lauryn Hill
miss education education that's a good
trait know what I like about that album
is the skits skits are very uh they're
there they're not utilized properly now
they're not they're not and that's what
I want to do on my album I want to do do
it right like the like off the time I
had I'm sure there's other examples but
the best example I can think of
skill-wise was like college dropout late
registration Kanye made the skits mean
son he really did and that's like that's
kind of what i want to do like it's
about soaking up game and learning it
and learning how to put it into Yoshi
okay so man ever since [__] you're
dizzy be flashing you tatted up you
smoke a lot of bud cats always [__]
try to throw the Wiz collab at you at
first or the Wiz The Wiz comparison you
know is that um because i was with Wiz
like two years ago many [__] with you
he knows who you are that's for damn
sure but is there um been any sort of
dialogue between you two but maybe
looking up no I didn't know he may be a
joint you guys could smoke together
literally man I would love to work with
Wiz like where's is one of them dudes
that took that route of building it fan
by fan you know exactly what you guys
are doing right now yeah and it's like
you know I definitely learned a lot from
his grind and [__] I would love to work
with him I haven't necessarily talked to
him I just don't I'll be running you run
into this you run into him and like you
know you got a viper that's what's up by
Southwest is for those coming over Sam
connecting with mother yo that's what's
gonna ask you last year south by um I
saw you what was that was that a Pandora
joint you did was Macklemore headlined
it you came out for the Pandora joint
Jesus Christ what's going on over there
um then like I saw that I saw you then
then I saw the progression at rock the
bells when you add that festival stage
rocking in San Bernardino
now rock the bells are south by your
second go-around you know I'm saying
being with funk volume what is the
difference now you've is it I know
you're doing bigger stages like you said
you just headline my [__] but like have
you noticed the difference man i mean
the progression is crazy man the last
year yeah you know what I what's crazy
is this is the year where like all the
artists like the big names is kind of
like yelled dizzy like they kind of lied
by who movie whoever you ran into
somebody Oh Jay rock like that was a
running into jay rock and j-rok [__]
with me yo Jay recognized ever shot like
isaiah rashad you too homie he's very
humble dude man but Jay rock though I
didn't even know if he knew me I'm like
a fan when I you know I you just love
j-roc poker you go to walk to be good
yeah but he really showed a lot of love
Nipsey Hussle like I ran into Nipsey
Hussle and like he just showed a lot of
love Technine like you know just [__]
a really problem i ran in the problem
fat Trel like a lot of [__] who
created something for this so you know
accepting what I got going on they like
yo keep doing that [__] that positive
[__] you're doing my [__] and that [__]
means everything to me
so uh so eps coming out first and then
album time after that for the end of the
year anything early early 2015 10
looking like I'm Shauna imma try to
catch the end of the year you know like
I know deadlines have to be met you know
that Mon you guys have deadlines at funk
I'm we didn't but when you want to do it
big so it goes in stores and the whole
world could get to it you know you gotta
follow rules because and can you getting
can um like last question man Hopsin
he's such a cool ass Justin he's the
most like normal ass dude like that's
why people [__] with him like a go skate
with his fans and [__] but like being
like Hopsin has been the spearhead of
funk volume of course he started a label
you're like you know getting up there
with him dude is like a recruit's
low-key ha like hot fall off him at one
time a little bit like you told me like
we're talking to Phoenix he told me as I
man I want a [__] retire and go to
Australia yeah like what's it like kind
of like now the spotlights on you funk
volume I think I think pom-pom buying
people think about you just as much to
think about hot now man like I think I'm
in this label everybody wants what they
want you know and um hop just you know
he's his own person like but me man I've
been the same you know me yeah you know
and that ain't never gonna change like I
met hops in it and he told me what he
wanted and you know things kind of
changed and I'm cool with that but it's
like he gonna do what he wanted to do
and you know
um I just gotta accept that in there by
God is he gonna do what he's gonna do as
well I appreciate the time my brother
man much love